[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
yes
it is friday
we made it
here
and there are tapes
[Music]
i'm not just talking about the p tapes
i'm talking about the tapes that trump
is threatening to release
this is not gonna go well for him this
is gonna
releasing these tapes of the fbi
searching his home is gonna go over
like a wet fart and a white thong for
him
it really truly is it's not gonna be
good
he always thinks oh well we'll just be
transparent of my crimes and as long as
i'm transparent of my crimes then they
can't they can't get me
he did this with
the first impeachment you remember oh is
the perfect phone call perfect with you
read the transcript remember they kept
saying that read the transcript read the
transcript read the transcript the
problem here
that he's going to have
is this is not the republican party that
is
that we're expecting to indict and
convict him
that is not what we're he's up against
here he is up against the department of
justice is what he is up against
that's what he's up against he is not up
against
the republican senate
his back is against the wall for the doj
and i don't know what he's trying to
prove here
rather the fbi did or didn't
take those boxes out of his house i'm
not exactly sure what their what their
idea that this is proof of
i mean the world's it's not like the
world doesn't believe that the fbi went
and
retrieved these classified documents
that he had
jesus christ they're all but admitting
it i mean at first they're like no what
documents there's no documents they just
were rustling through melania's
underwear drawer
and they were like oh yeah the 12 boxes
with the inventory that shows that
there's classified documents oh whoops
well they're not actually classified
he's a magician
he can wave his magic wand and say
they're not classified
oh yeah that's not a thing either
oops that's not a thing
rudy giuliani last night
was saying that he stole them to
preserve them you ever heard of that
you ever heard of that you ever go into
a store and see something you're like i
can't afford it but you know what i'm
gonna do
out of the kindness of my heart
and the kindness of my heart since i
can't afford this thing and i can't
really have it i'm gonna take this thing
home and preserve it
that's my justification for lifting it
and you know
they'll buy that
the police officers who come to arrest
me will definitely buy that argument
oh my god
these people
christina bob puts her foot in her mouth
this uh um habba or habba
i don't know this attorney who knows
she's some kind of ambulance chaser
apparently she knows a lot she knows a
lot about class of the eye documents
apparently
not
another lawyer bone-headed lawyer that
is out on the television tubes the
traitor tv networks trying to pimp for
trump
on this idea that he did not commit any
crimes and they run head first into this
thing every single time they're running
head first into the truth the truth is
that there is an fbi investigation the
department of justice is looking into
the classified documents what he took
and what he didn't
one of the statutes that they're using
to look into this is the espionage act
these are facts these are things that
are laid before us
now rather he broke these statues or not
that's gonna be up for a [ __ ] jury to
decide
but the simple fact remains he had boxes
and boxes of our documents that he did
not use protocol to have custody of
those documents
those are the [ __ ] facts
and him releasing the tape of the fbi
doing the thing that we know they did
it's not going to change those facts
folks
so the only thing that he's trying to do
by releasing these tapes is to expose
these fbi agents that's what they're
trying to do what what trump is trying
to do here is trying to threaten the
government
with releasing the tapes with unredacted
to to release the faces of the fbi
agents putting those agents and their
families and friends in danger
because we are dealing with domestic
terrorists here
believe me i have clips to show you on
oan that they are calling for violence
that elections are not enough
because they know they know this
election is going to go bad for them
because you are engaged
pro-democracy people out there have had
a [ __ ] nuff they watched the vote in
kansas and realized they totally [ __ ]
up
they went way too far
and that their party won't stop going
further they know they're gonna lose the
house they definitely know they're gonna
lose the senate even mitch mcconnell is
saying yeah we're not gonna we're not
gonna keep the senate
we're not gonna keep the senate because
donald trump is a [ __ ] idiot he won't
shut his mouth he won't just slink away
to mar-a-lago and retire
one of the arguments that his lawyers
are making is that oh if he if he would
just go away
they would they would stop pursuing him
well not anymore
maybe maybe when he lost the election my
8 million votes and he should have
conceded before the state certified the
votes
and slinked away after the january 20th
maybe just maybe if he had not committed
crimes on his way out of the white house
by stealing our government documents but
stealing classified information breaking
the espionage act apparently
then they would have left him the [ __ ]
alone probably they would have left him
to launder russians money for the less
of the for the rest of his pathetic life
but that is not what happened
he won't shut up he won't stop he's a
chaos agent it's the only thing he knows
to hang on to power that is it
and the only power he has left
is to rile up his base
and hopefully he's crossing his fingers
that they'll commit mass acts of
violence and save him and make him
dictator and king that way he doesn't
get to go to prison
that's his hope
and that's why he wants to release these
fbi tapes that's why
ultra maga
the america first nazi party these white
christian nationalists are cheering that
he that he released these tapes
it doesn't show that he did or didn't
commit crime it doesn't show that the
fbi went above and beyond the warrant
it's not what it shows
what it shows is the faces of the fbi
agents so they can threaten the
government
this is an act of domestic terrorism is
what it is it's a threat of domestic
terrorism it should be treated as much i
mean i'm all for them releasing the
tapes to be quite honest with you what
who gives a [ __ ] really
but the goal is not to show people what
happened the goal is to show who did it
and threaten those [ __ ] people that
is the goal
and they're threatening the government
by doing that
that's what they're doing
so
it's up to you
it's up to you
you can sit this one out and say you
know what this is done or you can lean
into democracy here
i know my audience is done with this
[ __ ] absolutely done with this stupid
ass trumpism [ __ ] this america first
nazi party
american fascism
nazis and maga hats they're just tired
of the [ __ ] domestic terrorists jesus
christ they called themselves that at
the nuremberg rally in texas
the last cpac they had
their domestic terrorists that's what
they are they're gonna continue i'm
gonna show you [ __ ] videos of
the heart of the party today to prove
this to you that this fbi release of
these of these cc uh or the trump fbi
executing a search warrant the tapes of
his closed caption television his
security cameras is nothing but trying
to enact domestic terrorism to try to
stoke violence jesus christ they've been
doing it and since he released his
little statement crying about how
they're holding him accountable for
committing crimes
so
it's going to be an interesting um
couple months here in the lead up to the
midterm election it's going to be a very
interesting couple of months
but we have to expose these people to
anyone you can who is going to vote
they've lost the narrative
the tail is definitely wagging the dog
and it's out of control
they don't know where to go they don't
know what lie to tell
they're in big trouble the republicans
have been for a long time but it is
clear now the american people understand
that they are in complete disarray not
only they are in disarray they're ready
and willing to turn this into a fascist
state to get rid of books and book fairs
get rid of women's rights
they want to tell you
marjorie taylor green wants to tell you
what you can and cannot identify as
they literally they want the biggest
type of government they possibly can
have in your [ __ ] pants
and it won't stop there
it will not stop there
in tennessee they trying to pass bills
to marry children
they want to tell parents how and how
they can and cannot raise their kids
they want to take their consent away
they're doing that in states
by telling parents who have transgender
kids or who simply don't know their
identification they're criminals the
parents are criminals and we must we
must take custody away from
them they're trying to dump
loads and truckloads
of assault weapons and weapons of war on
our streets into the hands of these
manga lunatics
to stoke fear the same way the same way
the guy in cincinnati went to the fbi
headquarters
the same way they say oh thoughts and
prayers
when someone goes and absolutely cuts up
with a weapon of war an 18 year old
child goes and kills other little
children at a school
and two teachers
oh thoughts and pray
we'll we'll build fences and and put
locks on doors
by the way by the way speaking of locks
on doors
that's another excuse he had a lock on
the door i mean what's the big deal he
had a lock on the door where the
documents were and there were only a
handful of people that were allowed to
go where those were we're not really
sure who they are but they weren't those
where people were allowed to go there
give me a [ __ ] break
here
the reason why they want to release this
tape is they want to release domestic
terrorism on our country
that is the goal here that's why they're
excited that's why manga is excited this
morning they're super excited
about donald trump releasing the
surveillance tape of the fbi search
warrant
because it will reveal the faces and
they know it will
the fbi has already already i guess
contacted the news agencies
and said if this tape gets released
unredacted with the faces not blurred we
want you to blur the faces to protect
our agents well you know you know
there's certain news agencies that
absolutely will not do that
and the ones who will not blur and will
not redact the faces of the agents and
the identity of the agents
are the ones that the domestic
terrorists are watching
that's what this is is this is a call
for terrorism
and he's gonna continue to do this folks
he's not gonna stop this stuff
and the way that he's doing it and the
approach that he's taking is always the
approach that he's had
he wants to stand 50 feet away
and said well they're upset i mean look
at them they're so upset
they they want to commit violence maybe
you should stop you know
holding me accountable and i'll tell
them to stop
same thing that happened on january 6.
same thing
you've heard you've heard the testimony
you've heard the phone calls you've
heard the testimony about kevin mccarthy
calling and asking him to stop
and kevin mccarthy was told by the
cheeto dust mobster maybe they just love
their country more than you do and what
he meant was maybe they love me
more than you do kevin
but they're fully aware how this
election's gonna go
they're fully aware
because they know you're [ __ ] pissed
they know you are [ __ ] pissed
the generic ballot is not going in their
direction
meaning the majority of the country
is saying well we much rather have
democrats than republicans running this
[ __ ]
in basic terms
it's we're much better off
the sad part is is it seems there's only
about a four or five percent uh markup
on that
whoosh
that's a sign
to donald trump that he can he can
convince
his dumbest loyalist supporters
to possibly
protect him
by making sure that he releases the
identities
of the fbi agents who were doing their
job that day
when they went to get the boxes of
classified documents that he
did not legally have in his possession
it was illegal in his possession that's
why they went and took them
this is really [ __ ] ridiculous
that we have to do this
but this is where we're at
and the reason why is because donald
trump allowed
and gave permission for white
christian nationalist
america first nazis to crawl out
underneath their rocks
and think it is okay
to say and do the things
that will hurt other americans and to
overturn our democracy that is what they
want because democracy is
their
enemy
forget the press
you know he always said the press is the
enemy of the state no
the enemy of their party
is democracy it's you
and democracy is you the voice of the
people that is what their enemy is here
just like in kansas
the enemy was the people of the fascist
party in kansas who wanted to strip away
the rights of women in kansas the right
to their bodily autonomy
the people in kansas the democracy in
kansas said not just no but hell no
[ __ ]
you will not take away my [ __ ] rights
you can go get bent
people who didn't engage in politics
voted on that measure and that measure
alone
and i'm very confident very confident if
you engage in your democracy and you get
like-minded folks that really want to
protect our way of life
our democracy
the advances that we have made here
and and the progress that we can
continue to make
i encourage you to engage in your
democracy
and use the tool of your ballot to do
that not just mark the ballot
again to engage in your democracy you
have to yell you have to scream you have
to talk to your community members
the folks at the pta at your church at
your work
the people at the grocery store that you
run into your family your friends make
it about community
because it is working there is a there
is a sea change folks
even from 2020 there's a sea change if
you have not been watching some of these
community meetings that beto o'rourke is
holding i've got one to show you where
he absolutely dunks on greg abbott
as greg abbott supporters are showing up
at beto o'rourke these community
meetings that he's having
but there's a seed change
the tide is turning on this fascism
people are [ __ ] sick and done with
trumpism they're done with it
they don't want to be told that you
can't read books they don't want to be
told about the [ __ ] genitalia in
their pants they don't want you thinking
about their children's genitalia and
passing laws on it they just don't want
the nonsense they don't want to hear
your [ __ ] about critical race theory
they don't want to hear your [ __ ]
nonsense about cueing on conspiracy
theories they are sick and tired of
hearing about an election that happened
two [ __ ] years ago
and we done know that that election was
the one of the free and fairest
elections that we've had in this country
when we're just months away from the
next one you can't stop bitching about
the last one shut the [ __ ] up
is the consensus of america to trumpism
i feel
i just hope they make that shut the [ __ ]
up heard and felt
because if we do that if we actually
engage in this election and we take this
2022 midterm
and dunk this america fascist party
in the [ __ ] trash
it will send a message
not just to them but to all people who
are allies in democracy
we don't all agree
i know there's plenty of people who come
here every day who believe in democracy
but listen to some of the [ __ ] i say and
say tony you're wrong and they may be to
the left of me they may be to the right
of me what the [ __ ] ever who gives a
[ __ ]
the point is we have one
one common thread
in america
and that is our liberty
that's it our liberty that's what we
strive for
that's what democracy ultimately should
deliver us
it's difficult it's hard i'll admit it
again a lot of you do not agree with
half the [ __ ] i say
i'm okay with that you don't even some
people come here and watch me and don't
even like the words that i use
because i curse a lot
that's okay that's fine
[ __ ] you probably don't agree on some of
my stances
as far as the democratic party but we
can agree all agree on one thing that
there's only one party only one in this
moment in history at this very time that
even gives a [ __ ]
about democracy
and making sure that people have liberty
only [ __ ] one the other party wants
to do the exact opposite they want to
tear our democracy down they want to
take away liberty from people who aren't
them
sounds familiar i don't know the 30s and
40s kind of comes to mind
and i'm going to show you the proof
today over and over and over again i
tell you don't look away
and it's not just about looking away you
have to show people these things
i'm going to show you a video today that
shows carrie lake's best friend carrie
lake's campaign manager
practically
talking about putting lgbtq people in
concentration camps
this is what the gop has become
they want to put
lgbtq
community
our rainbow army our our allies in the
fight for democracy
and our fellow human beings and
americans
carrie lake's
biggest supporter
wants to make sure that they set up
concentration camps i'm not [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
i wouldn't you're my favorite turd
and you can't look away but the most
important thing is to spread the [ __ ]
news that these people have lost their
goddamn minds
they are out to lunch they have they
have not
been in reality for a quite some time
they need to tether back to it but until
then we cannot trust them to even be the
goddamn dog catcher
their interest is not policy
their interest
is not the american people
their interest is not democracy
the interest is power
and to use that power
to enforce their fascism on this state
and i'm not just talking about your
state that you live in definitely your
state that you live in but your county
your local government your school board
the united states government they want
to tear it all to the ground
and they want to do it when they have
power so they can build it back
in their image of the america first nazi
party
the gop trumpism
that is what they want and we must stand
in their way we the people we the
government it's ours
just like those documents down at
mar-a-lago were our documents
[ __ ] that guy if you guys want to
support pro-democracy speech today don't
forget to go visit the link down at the
bottom support.tonymichaelspod.com
you can help support this show we air
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 center on youtube
twitter and twitch
and simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page for two full hours there's
also a qr code down there that you can
use to get to that link
today's friday and you know what happens
on friday bonehead of the week
we have the boneheads that you voted you
decided on twitter and youtube so follow
us on twitter at tonymichael's pod don't
forget to vote there every single week
for bonehead of the week
today in the second hour me and my
co-host and executive producer gabe
sanchez will break down your vote
because you decide who is the bonehead
of the week and we break it down
so stay tuned for the second hour when
we go through bonehead of the week don't
forget to subscribe to the tony michaels
podcast while you're here push that
subscribe button click the bell
notification whatever else you're
supposed to do on youtube
i guess that's what i'm supposed to say
also if you like listening to the
podcast thank you very much we've had a
ton of new downloads thank you for
downloading download download download
on apple spotify google your favorite
directory don't forget to leave us a
great review while you're there
download every single episode
fast forward to your favorite part
re-listen to that favorite part
or just re-listen to the music in the
beginning a lot of people have been
talking about the music in the beginning
in the intro
i like the intro i like the waiting
music we were a little late getting on
the air today i apologize
we're running just a bit behind but we
are here it is the bottom of the first
hour we are gonna go through the [ __ ]
list roundup before we get to bonehead
of the week because you know that's one
of our favorite parts as a shitlist
roundup so stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
after these messages and we will surf
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
stick around we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new maga skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
got a lot of videos to show you again
today every single day
weirdos won't stop making videos
they just can't they just can't help
themselves
these fascists
oh boy i got some evidence for you today
to show around to your family and
friends about why it is so important
that the midterm elections is the most
important election of your lifetime to
get that through their thick skull that
you cannot let these people take power
anywhere absolutely anywhere especially
in arizona as the governor's race i'm
going to show you uh kerry lake's best
friend and avid supporter and apparently
it seems like a campaign messenger
that's what it seems like that's the
other thing we you gotta remember we
have to politicize everything everyone
kind of oh tony easy easy don't say
those words those are bad no we have to
politicize every single thing it is
super important right now in politics
because again
i've said this before and i'll say it a
million more times there's two things
there's government which is policy which
is the things you want you know you want
a
certain
wage
so that you're not going broke because
of your wage you want to make sure that
you don't go bankrupt because of a
medical bill you want your children to
start school at three instead of five
you want to make sure that you don't go
broke because you want to get an
education after high school
you know those sorts of things those
sorts of policy things in government
well guess what that's government what
we have to do first is we have to do the
politics so we got to win the elections
we have to politicize the [ __ ] out of
everything to win these elections we
cannot stop we cannot let up we have to
lean into it
lean into it [ __ ] them [ __ ] them [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them if they don't like it
well then they can give up because we're
not that's the attitude that we need to
have because they're not going away
folks i don't know if you noticed this
but these trump these trump lights these
moguladites they're not slinking away
anytime soon
they think they have permission to take
over our country they believe they can
do it with domestic terrorism and
violence for that matter
so it's time for us to fight back and to
lean into our democracy and use the tool
of our ballot
and cast these people out these
boneheads
speaking of bone heads here in about 30
minutes we're gonna do bonehead of the
week but let's do this first
one of your favorite segments here on
the tony michaels podcast where we surf
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
let's start the shitless roundup start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome
welcome welcome back to the show you
have reached the part where we surf the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
we go through the [ __ ] list roundup
we got a lot of [ __ ] to round up today
let's go through the timeline let's make
this a little bigger so you can see
okay um there there's a video here and i
pinned it to the top it's chelsea
handler and i believe she's filling in
for
jimmy
kimmel or something
on a late night show i'm not sure maybe
she has her own late night show i'm not
really i'm not really sure
but she does a master class
in handling these boneheads now i will
warn you
i will warn you that if if you're
watching re-watching this on youtube
and you're not you're not hearing the
video
it's probably because they dinged us for
copyright so if you can't hear the video
here
of chelsea talking it's probably because
they they dinged us but you can go to
the twitter page just go to my twitter
page at the tony michaels and you can
find this video of chelsea handler
um
masterfully
undoing
the biggest bonehead of them all lauren
bobert the clown listen is one of the
biggest maga morons ever elected to
public office and it's because of
comments like this
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
okay well let's think about that you
dumb [ __ ]
oh boy
oh boy because i tend to be skeptical
about getting constitutional law advice
from a human [ __ ] stamp
oh wait i gotta i gotta stop there human
[ __ ] stamp is that not the best
nickname for lauren bober like there's
been a lot of them there's been a lot
i've tried out a lot i've floated a lot
of nicknames but but human [ __ ] stamp i
mean it absolutely perfect defines
lauren bobert to a t she's a walking
human [ __ ] stamp chelsea hats off to
you they frequently tend to skip right
to the second amendment and if you
bother to read the first amendment the
very first words are congress shall make
no law respecting an establishment of
religion so it seems pretty clear that
the government wants nothing to do with
religion secondly if you're so keen on
what the founding fathers thought one
thing they definitely thought is that
women should shut up in public
and not vote and not be elected to
congress your buddy thomas jefferson
wrote governments are instituted among
men so unless you haven't
the founding fathers don't care what you
have to say
but lauren i don't think you do have it
do you i know your husband does because
he allegedly showed it to some young
ladies in a bowling alley
and again this is a master class on how
to handle these [ __ ] boneheads it's a
master class on how to handle them and
handle people who support them
this is even more important
this is even more important when you
have someone standing in front of you
acting like lauren beaure to some kind
of smart person
you absolutely tear into them and use
these arguments
it's time we fight for [ __ ] for some
goddamn clarity here it's time we fight
for just simple [ __ ]
common sense not even facts i mean
the fact that she actually is walking
around and people are applausing and
cheering
that the founding fathers didn't want
separation between church and state is
the dumbest [ __ ] thing i've ever
heard of in my life
again chelsea lays it out in the first
[ __ ] sentence the first sentence the
reason why the [ __ ] came here
the reason why they stayed here the
reason why they fought to have a country
in the [ __ ] first place
you [ __ ] boneheads
all you gotta do is tear them apart with
this master class
that chelsea handler is giving you well
and you can come watch this show every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific because i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna shy away from showing you
these clips just like chelsea wasn't
gonna shy away from showing this
audience
the clip of lauren bobert acting like
the separation of church and state is
bogus [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you lauren bobert we'll go right
after you we'll lean into democracy
let's keep listening
and let's all take a moment to remember
that the founding fathers were a bunch
of toothless
dudes who took chadubies in their
backyard
thought that their wives were property
and wanted to protect guns that fired
marbles and took 11 minutes to reload
and since we're paraphrasing jefferson's
letters he said nothing is so disgusting
as a woman who is it clean
nothing is more disgusting than a woman
who isn't clean that almost is
better than human tram stamp what do you
think
and while you're there google lauren
bobert diarrhea
and you will learn that this dumbass
owned a restaurant that served uncooked
pork sliders at a rodeo which gave
dozens of people diarrhea
[Applause]
that's how lauren forces people to pray
they cry out please god stop me from
making explosive diarrhea poo poo in
this rodeo porta body
[Applause]
oh chelsea handler thank you very much
again for giving us a master class on
how to handle lauren bobert and these
white christian nationalists now here's
a prime example if you have someone out
there that's standing in front put this
in your bookmarks
put this tweet in your bookmarks it's at
the top
of my profile right now at the tony
michaels
on twitter go
take this video put it in your bookmarks
and when some dumb [ __ ]
bonehead is talking about stupid-ass
[ __ ]
like lauren beaubert marger tay the
green christian white nationalist your
uncle earl starts talking about how
lauren beau were so [ __ ] smart oh the
stuff she says i love that stuff get
this video out get this video out and
show him what a real woman thinks
of lauren bobert
an actual thinking person someone i
don't know
who takes 30 seconds
30 seconds to do a little bit of
research to understand exactly what the
constitution [ __ ] says
it's not difficult because uncle earl
your uncle earl who loves lauren bobert
has never read the constitution
he'll say the word constitution
constitution second amendment second
amendment it's my son two-way i'm a
two-way bro
bang bang bang bang bang i gotta have my
guns because
constitutions he's never read it he's
never read the [ __ ] constitution
never
because he's a [ __ ] idiot just like
lauren bobert your uncle earl is a
[ __ ] idiot
i hate to tell you my uncle earl is a
[ __ ] idiot everyone's uncle earl who
loves lauren bobert who wears a maga hat
is a [ __ ] idiot
so get this video out and show this to
them now it's gonna piss them off it's
gonna piss them off they're not gonna i
mean they're not gonna go bing oh you're
right you're right she's a dumb [ __ ] and
i
but you know what it might do it might
just get inside their head just enough
just that little morsel
little morsel of doubt
that maybe this person isn't as smart as
i think they are
maybe just maybe he'll
i don't know
go dust off that pocket constitution
that he used to carry around and read
the [ __ ]
maybe just maybe probably not but maybe
we got a lot of clips of lawyers
did you see this yesterday trump trotted
out all his lawyers
you know why do you know why trump
trotted out all his lawyers on on
television last night why they were all
over tv
saying stupid-ass [ __ ] having stupid-ass
arguments basically incriminating him in
some cases do you know why the reason
why is because everyone has been
reporting that no one will defend him an
actual lawyer who deals with classified
information cases
who know about classified information in
very
very legal d
very stringent legal detail
in other words someone whose specialty
is to do litigation
tied to classified documents
and the possession of them the espionage
act and on and on and on
he can't find anyone so he has to rely
on the on the army of dum-dums that he
has and the army of dum-dums went out on
the [ __ ] news channels yesterday
and absolutely puked up a bunch of
[ __ ] garbage hmm who'da thunk it
and again in some cases it seems like
they may have even incriminated him
which is absolutely batshit crazy that
these lawyers are saying anything but
this case is ongoing the investment we
are cooperating the investigation is
ongoing we have been cooperating
i can't speak to what the fbi doj is
going to do we know we have done nothing
wrong my client says he's done nothing
wrong and that's our story
not giving details about the what the
[ __ ] happened with the documents
who are these where did they get their
goddamn law license
in what state
do you go and you have to you can be
this [ __ ] irresponsible
this derelict in your duty and pass the
bar and continue to hold the law license
are you [ __ ] kidding me the likes of
uh jenna ellis the fart sniffer jenna
ellis rudy giuliani who's already lost
his law license
you have christina bob the [ __ ]
seditionist the goddamn traitor
does anyone know who christina bob is
this is very important this is very
[ __ ] important
christina bob is the one who helped
draft the [ __ ] cheeto dust kangaroo
coup memo
with john eastman there's another
[ __ ] lawyer that's in big [ __ ]
trouble here now he wasn't on tv
yesterday as far as i know
he's not exactly defending trump anymore
officially i don't know maybe i i think
he's probably turned on him at this
point
that's why that's why we that's why we
got scott perry the story of scott perry
getting his cell phone seized
but christina bob was in the war room
folks
she was in the war room during january 6
trying to help steve bannon rudy
giuliani and john eastman overturn our
government
that's who that is everyone's like oh
she's a former oan host and trump's
attorney
that is not who she is
she was
an oan host but that was all a [ __ ]
ruse
that was all the push of [ __ ]
narrative
that trump was gonna what trump was
gonna lose because there was fraudulent
votes and this [ __ ] dominion machine
thing you remember she was the one who
went down and helped raise funds in
arizona for the fro
for the fraud it
where they were looking for bamboo
ballots and [ __ ] you remember the cyber
ninjas
where maricopa county had to buy all new
[ __ ] machines because these people
compromised them
because they didn't know what the [ __ ]
they were doing when they were handling
election data that christina bob she's a
[ __ ] traitor
she's out on [ __ ] tv
defending another traitor hmm
and in a way that
incriminates him but the first one i
want to start with
is the fart sniffer you remember who i'm
talking about jenna ellis the farts
never you know the one that rudy
giuliani farted on
in that hearing
grandpa farty mcarty that's where he got
his nickname i call rudy giuliani
grandpa farty mchardy some like rudy
kaluti but i like grandpa farty mchardy
and the reason why is because of the
incident where he farted on jenna ellis
in a hearing and it was obvious the hot
mic picked it up that hot fart up
[Music]
and boy she was sniffing that covered
for it like crazy
but here's jenna ellis on i don't know
some trader news network they can't they
can't go on a regular network anymore
which is good i'm the mainstream media
should not invite these [ __ ] on
they're nothing but a bunch of liars and
traitors
we can watch them from afar on the
trader news networks and watch them
incriminate themselves
well
let's
listen uh this is about as boneheaded as
the lauren bobert stuff but let's go
here we go
and the fact that the raid itself wasn't
even leaked and that you know cnn wasn't
there with its cameras at 8 am already
at mar-a-lago okay
so what she's saying here is that
because cnn was not there
with their cameras
is indication that the fbi didn't want
this to leak now
i think she's actually correct here in
that the fbi did not
want
the public to know about this and the
reason why they were really iffy about
the public knowing about this is because
of the domestic terrorists that support
donald trump they don't want another
okus homa city bombing
they don't want it they they are trying
to avoid violence in this country
but they have to hold these people to
account
they have to and they're going to it's
clear that they're going to
so the fbi and probably that what we're
going to see from the tapes
when trump releases them because he's
going to folks he's going to release
them because he has no other option here
he's running out of stories he's running
out of lies so the lie that the tape
will show you that he was
he was some injustice was done on him is
going to be another lie he'll show you
the tape we'll see that it's a lie and
he'll try to move to the next one and
the next one and the next one because
these lies aren't working the american
people aren't buying it
just like they're not buying this
[ __ ] that's being puked up out of
jenna ellis's mouth look at this
screenshot by the way look at this
freeze from frame oh
he's really digging that look on her
face let's go just shows that likely the
fbi was trying to just go in under cover
of darkness and just go in and get what
they did it during the day
they did it during the day you [ __ ]
idiot
they were there for hours and hours
they didn't go and bust down the door
with flashlights and guns and swat team
at three o'clock in the morning
that's where this falls apart when they
call it a raid which everyone's like
don't say the word raid well why not i g
they raided him
they raided him for the [ __ ] evidence
that he committed crimes yeah sure
here we go whatever what wanted uh under
this pretext of a raid and it's only
because president trump is so
underestimated by the left and he uses
media to his advantage
okay so here's where it gets to here's
where it gets to that she's going to
claim here that trump is 12 steps ahead
of the left
which i don't even know what the hell
that means
i don't even know what the hell that
means he's not 12 steps ahead of the
left here he's going to have to stay 12
steps ahead of the department of justice
this is not a [ __ ] pr problem
that's the problem that they're gonna
have here in the very end
and they're not going to be able to
avoid it jesus christ mike flynn is even
saying that trump's going to be indicted
here this is not a pr problem this is
not an impeachment problem this is not
rather his party is going to remove him
from an office problem
this is how long and for what are you
gonna go to prison for
that's the problem that you have it's a
criminal indictment it's a legal problem
and here the attorney who is supposed to
be an attorney
is saying on television telling the
audience that this is in the league it's
a pr problem
deluding them folks there's nothing
better than this
and this is why they're going to be so
[ __ ] upset but this is what their
plan is is to get these people to
believe a bunch of [ __ ] nonsense and
the opposite happen
and it'll stoke more fear and more anger
because their support is dwindling down
to the most delusional and the most
violent
and they know it jenna ellis knows it
this traitor tv news network knows it
donald trump knows it the department of
justice knows it that's why the
department of justice is begging that
the news agencies if he does release
this blur the faces of the fbi agents
and that's what trump is doing that's
what jen ellis is doing that's what
they're all doing is threatening us he
is the one that actually blew the
whistle on this on the fbi i think they
had no idea and no intention that this
would ever become public and that they
would be fighting this fight and i
didn't give credits and the fact that
that it would never become public so
their goal their goal here is to for it
not to become public get the [ __ ] out of
here
get out of here with this [ __ ]
you want to see another you want to see
another ridiculous lawyer well he's not
a lawyer anymore
he was the person who farted
on the fart sniffer we just watched
grandpa farting mccarty rudy giuliani
here's rudy giuliani's uh newest lie
and really honestly the craziest part
about this clip
with rudy giuliani because they do this
all the time i'm going to show you
another clip of tucker carlson doing the
exact same thing they run face first
fate i mean head first into the truth
and they still have head up ass syndrome
aneuryocranial dysfunction
they still can't figure it out watch
and and now
they want to make them responsible for
having taken classified documents
and preserve them
okay so what what rudy giuliani here is
saying is oh they're gonna punish him
for preserving doc get the [ __ ] out if
he wanted to preserve documents if he
really wanted to there's an actual
protocol
with the national archives to preserve
these documents
there is an actual protocol and that's
what that's what the department of
justice is actually alleging here that
he did not follow that proper protocol
which means he had illegal possession of
these documents it doesn't matter if he
wanted to preserve them
what are you talking about he's gonna
can him keep him to eat them later
you know he didn't want to eat him right
then he didn't want to eat him right
then so he's going to preserve him so he
can eat him later the [ __ ] out of here
really if you look at the espionage act
oh oh he here geordie giuliani is about
to educate us on their espionage act
this is where he runs into the truth
and doesn't even see it here we go it's
not really about taking the documents
it's about destroying them
or hiding them
uh give him to the enemy
okay let's listen to that one more time
this is what rudy giuliani believes
that the espionage act is about and in a
nutshell
the last three things that he's talking
about that is the crimes that are kind
of laid out in the espionage act he's
kind of right about that regardless of
how drunk rudy is here a broken clock or
a drunk clock as it is here is right
twice a day watch really about taking
the documents
it's about destroying them or hiding
them
or giving them to the enemy right okay
so
if the espionage act is about those
three things hiding them taking them or
are just hiding them destroying them are
giving to the enemy
and the fbi has enough probable cause
and evidence to get a federal judge
to issue a warrant to go
seek the evidence for i don't know
hiding them
destroying them or selling them to the
enemy
what the [ __ ] do you think they wouldn't
got that [ __ ] for so if it is it one of
the three things or is it all three
things rudy
this is really [ __ ] dumb runs head
first into the truth here runs headfirst
into the point and doesn't even realize
it look at the look on this drunk
motherfucker's face look at him still
can't figure it out and ain't no wonder
he ain't got a law license anymore you
[ __ ] dummy right it's not about
taking them and putting them in a place
that's roughly as safe as they were in
the first place
roughly roughly as
some of these documents were were in a
skiff
we're in a skiff you can't even take
recording devices in this gif get that
black out of here with this roughly the
same sort of locked away as they were
before give me a break these people are
absolutely out of their minds
out of
their minds speaking of out of our mind
out of their minds i'm going to show you
uh another attorney here we go
here's another one i'm not [ __ ] you
this was this was like the the
uh the the night the night of the
walking attorneys
you know the night of the walking dead
these these zombies come out and come on
tv and spew out [ __ ] that is not legal
well really again
they're really telling on themselves
here
they're really telling on them
themselves
watch this one she's telling on trump
again head first into the [ __ ] point
doesn't even realize it yeah well
there's three allegations right
concealment espionage and basically
destruction
oh so there's three of them there's
three of them and they had to have
probable cause to go get the evidence of
those three now i keep i keep telling
folks this uh and i want to say this
into the microphone again
they took 15 boxes
right they took 15 boxes we know they
took 15 boxes and in june
donald trump and his attorneys told the
department of justice or told the
national archives
and to pull the department of justice
that they had handed everything over
ever all the documents that he took he
handed them over now
you got to remember in trump's universe
the truth is a little obscure meaning
i'll say a sentence and everything in
the sentence is true
but out of context that's not the truth
right so they could say yes absolutely
when you came and got the first 15 boxes
you took every document that he took
from the white house
wink
the wink there is
i'm sure there's a copy machine at
mar-a-lago maybe there's a copy machine
in melania's closet
i'm not saying i know these things i'm
just saying that there is a possibility
the reason why think about this the
reason why they came back and got 12
boxes is because they did come and get
the original documents
they did come and get the original
documents but what stopped him during
that time period of making copies and
hiding copies
give me a break with this [ __ ]
of course that could be something but
the problem is is that everyone has this
anal cranial dysfunction the head up ass
syndrome what's let's hear more of her
diagnosis here all of which don't make
sense to me knowing that he was
cooperating the entire time yeah no he
wasn't they've already did it's already
reported that he was not cooperating
that's why they had to go back to get
more he wasn't doing what he said he was
doing
just because you're pretending to
cooperate doesn't mean you're actually
doing it just because you say and you
post on fraud social that you're
cooperating doesn't actually mean you're
doing that thing
it doesn't mean it i mean i could i
could i could post all kinds of things
and sell proclaim things
but it doesn't mean that's the actual
truth
and we know now that it's not the truth
because the fbi and the doj and a
federal judge decided that yeah that
he's not cooperating
so if you were concealing it you
wouldn't have allowed them in in june if
you were distracting it you wouldn't
have added the padlock that they asked
you to laugh oh my god
oh my god
not none of this makes any sense none of
it
none of it makes any sense whatsoever
it's not even not even i mean the dog
ate my homework is a better [ __ ]
excuse
than this one jesus
add-on in june or given them 15 boxes
all of these things as you've seen and
it's been reported have this caveat that
people get excited about which is that
he then cannot run for president
and this is what it's about this is what
it's about this is why she's on tv
listen to the words that she's about to
say and this is important because trump
is watching as she's doing this
interview and the one thing she is she
is uh
given an assignment for is to tell
everyone on newsmax that he still can
run for president don't let don't let
them think just because they indict me
for these documents
don't don't believe them when they say i
can't run because i want to still grift
you i want to still be able to convince
you that i may run even if i'm federally
indicted and convicted possibly on a
charge that would not allow me to hold
any kind of public office don't believe
that part because definitely don't
believe that because how would i make
money how would i have a i mean how
would i survive if i didn't grift off
you that's what they're saying here
that's what they're setting up
because they gotta have two things here
they gotta have they gotta have the the
domestic terrorist money and they gotta
have their their anger and violence
directed
at their enemies they don't understand
is presidents have different privileges
they have executive privileges they have
different things that have been in place
presidents do have those things by the
way
she's right presidents do the problem is
he's not the president
he's not the president
he's not and it doesn't matter how many
stupid ass [ __ ] believe that he
is the president it doesn't make him one
and the courts aren't going to [ __ ]
recognize that he's the president
because he's not
it's very simple
it's very simple but here the attorney
again is performing for one [ __ ]
only one [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] wants to believe that he
still has the power of the presidency
which he doesn't
from bush george w bush put in place
obama used but no one talks about that
because if it's true oh you guys talk
about it all the time
he's he's been [ __ ] talking about it
all [ __ ] week how barack obama
followed protocol and made sure that the
custody was correct of all the archives
going from washington dc to his
presidential library which you'll never
have you [ __ ] we better not give
that son of a [ __ ] a [ __ ] library
i'll be pissed i'll be more pissed if we
have to spend our [ __ ] money for a
goddamn building with his name on it
that says library then if he doesn't go
to prison you better well
damn better believe that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he does not get a library
we should not give that [ __ ] a
library he should have an asterisk next
to his name and those [ __ ] archives
and presidential records should be
buried in a bunker in the national
archives
until we until he's chokes on a [ __ ]
big mac and then we can release them and
let the country know how [ __ ]
dangerous this piece of [ __ ] was the
entire four years that they decided it
was a good idea that he run our country
and ran it into the god damn ground [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you don't get a library trump
they'd like to bring these antiquated
statutes and shove them down his equated
statues well they gotta
antiquated statutes oh you know like
laws
again a lawyer who doesn't know how to
lawyer worth a [ __ ] worth a [ __ ] doesn't
know how to lawyer here's another lawyer
i'm not kidding you i told you there's a
bunch of them i told you we're we're
even we're even up against bone end of
the week i got a text and gave here
we're at the second hour already and i
i'm not even done with the attorneys i
got to get to the crazies
yeah these aren't the crazies
these aren't even the crazies here's
christina bob the traitor
the the the half architect of the cheeto
dusk kangaroo memo the one that was in
the [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] war room trying to
overturn our government steve bannon
rudy giuliani and john eastman when they
were communicating with the oath keepers
and the proud boys trying to commit
violence at the capitol here we go just
move past uh sorry interrupt but was it
was there a limited number of people who
had access to that storage room it seems
like a pretty important room right since
they've made such a big deal of it and
have like oh they made such a big deal
yes it's an important room there's
[ __ ] classified documents in there
that can only be viewed in a skiff and
it's not one talk on it and so forth so
were there a limited number of people
who could go in and out
yes that would have access certainly
mar-a-lago it
certainly mar-a-lago is secure in and of
itself you know just getting on to
no it's not i want to remind everyone
and gabe sanchez our executive producer
reminded everyone that there was a
chinese national that was arrested at
mar-a-lago for
getting on the compound
carrying [ __ ] hard drives and all
computers and cell phones and all kinds
of [ __ ]
and they got on the compound what makes
anyone think that someone they're like
oh handfuls of people who knows who they
are we're not really sure who they are
there's not really a list per se i mean
donald trump whoever he wants whatever
you know saudi national that he wants to
see these documents and take pictures of
these documents they're allowed in [ __ ]
out of here the compound is hard and
then it was a locked door oh you know
back down into the basement there's
security you can't just walk down there
only certain members of staff can get
there and then there's only one i'm sure
uh yes it's a very who who hides the key
by the way do you think it's do you
think the one key is under the the floor
mat in front of the door it has to be
right there's no [ __ ] way
you're either that either that or it's
like it's it they it's like on a gold
chain and it's one of them big ass gold
chains around someone's neck i don't
know i'm just saying i'm sure the key is
underneath the mat though right or
there's like a little mailbox there by
the door
that you open the door and the keys in
and it's probably some fake ass gold key
right like some big huge [ __ ] gold
key like a skeleton key that says trump
on it or some [ __ ] come on you know
that's the truth it ain't just some
regular [ __ ] key no way
no way these people don't do anything
regular they always trump it up it's
always the wrestling match you know
we're at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life there's no way
it's just a normal key no [ __ ] way
limited number of people that have
access down there and
you know it was enough to where
president trump believed or our team
believed that it was secure enough they
asked for one more lock at another lock
which we did uh and then for whatever
reason they decided that they still
needed to raid the place
and only one or two people had access to
that room to your knowledge
that's my understanding i mean i would
have to check with you know the the
maintenance of that area but my unders
oh my god this is supposed to be the
head attorney the person that was on
site
be representing him in this raid
and she doesn't know how many people
have access to this room are you [ __ ]
kidding me
oh my god gabe sanchez tell me what you
think about these lawyers
man yeah the other man i'm not even to
the crazy i'm not even to the crazy [ __ ]
i'm just doing the lawyers at this point
i got two videos i want to show you of
crazies give us your synopsis of these
attorneys
uh
inexperienced way in over their head
uh
their
their
assumption of innocence is astounding
and
uh
every time they speak they give the
worst legal takes like the shitty legal
takes is what they do
you're telling me
that they have that they don't know what
they're talking about is that what
you're saying
look i'm just
i'm no lawyer
but
yes i am
you're saying that they it sucks to suck
kind of thing
it definitely definitely sucks to suck
i can't i can't i can't i can't follow
it because
it really seems like a really bad sitcom
you know what i mean like right
like there should be laugh tracks over
some of the [ __ ] they're saying that's
so weird because yeah i know
my computer started doing that
it started playing something in my in my
computer that was a laugh track oddly
enough yeah enough so you're saying that
there's a laugh track somewhere over top
these videos is that what you're saying
there might be and some and some do we
have one handy do we have one handy yeah
yeah we do well um load it up there load
the one you have handy up maybe maybe we
should show the audience
um
how this how how this should actually be
edited because and frankly some of the
stuff they're saying is really it's
[ __ ] laughable because christina bob
in in some respects is incriminating
trump in the statements that she's
making she's his attorney
she's the one who was on site apparently
she signed off on the [ __ ] the
paperwork when they left and she's like
i don't know how many people can get in
this room i'm not really sure i mean i
think there's a lock on it there's
possibly i think there's just one key
it's under the mat in front of the door
but i mean it's secure don't worry
there's security there well the fact
that she goes well there there was a
there's an extra padlock they put an
extra lock on there like that's like
like that it's like one of those you
know like i have a you know a crawl
space or like a storage space in in the
basement of our of our where we live and
you know it's one of those just easy
flaps that you screw in
oh and then you slide the lock in
you know what you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah that's what i imagine when
they're like put it in the lockout and
they're like okay sounds good and they
just drill that in
to where the door meets the frame and
then they slopped on a padlock and then
they called it a day and like this is
good enough right in a basement where
other people don't have access but
that's
not what happened in 2019
well the other thing that these
boneheads are claiming is that he was
cooperating since june which the reason
why they had to go back is because he
wasn't doing that yeah that's the whole
point of what they're trying to do
and really him releasing the tapes
because i don't know how much of a
hubbub this is going to be he's
obviously going to release these things
because he has no other lie to continue
right well he can't he keeps he keeps
putting himself in a corner to be like
oh this is unjust and unfair and they're
personally coming at me as an as an
attack
and then he says they should unseal the
search warrant and then you know the
republicans are like yeah yeah yeah
let's unseal the search warrant so they
do that and like okay fine we will
unseal this redacted and realize that he
was commending espionage right like oh
well maybe we should see that this and
then right well he was like oh we'll
release the affidavit which by the way
the affidavit
is going to be all but just
just black lines across it'll be like
right because you're right because the
judge is going to reject right exactly
because you don't want to reveal
the
uh the
the sources right where they're getting
information right that you don't want to
have that attack that's put on him so
he says release david david and then doj
is like okay fine we will release more
of the search warrant that justifies why
we should have gone into your place and
searched the property
and now he's like you know now they're
talking about like oh maybe we'll please
release the footage right and you had
you also had uh eric trump the other day
he was like oh we'll release it when the
time is right on sean hannity and it's
like no you won't release it because
it'll reveal that you guys [ __ ] up
right and well i actually i think i
think they're going to release this
footage now they're going to heavily
edit it right there's no way they're not
going to edit this thing and you're
probably going to see sparks where the
like humans are like
yeah yeah you know just horrible editing
because i'm sure eric's gonna actually
be the one who's editing this oh yeah
for sure honestly on his job right
but i mean
the thing is is that they're trying to
what this what this is trying to do is
trying to stoke violence because what
they really want to do is reveal who the
fbi agents are they want to they want to
dox the fbi agents this goal is to
threaten the government and the goal is
to have their their army of [ __ ]
delusional dumb [ __ ] threatening people
and and here's an example of one of them
now
this is um what the hell's her name i
called their i call their bonehead
barbie allison
yeah something let's see here's the
problem allison's something berg right
yeah
she said am i such a trunt um here's the
thing is that
the problem here is that they're only
talking to like five people because we
know that oan is like
they're
yeah their audience has been right both
it was verizon most recently and and att
before that so they're like i think the
only place on tv is like in alaska like
in the bush or something
that's it that's the only place you can
get this if you got a satellite dish in
alaska or some [ __ ] so there's like five
people watching this
but the point is is that this is their
rhetoric and this is where it starts
this is how the january 6th [ __ ] started
is these obscure places where these dumb
[ __ ] are saying this dumb [ __ ]
stoking this violence because this
person has a huge following
on on social media all these 2a bros
love how she looks and love how she
talks
and you're gonna know what i mean when i
play this clip but this person is
calling for violence in this clip that's
what i'm taking from it when she says
the word revolution and we can't rely on
elections anymore watch
that's how you start a revolution
we should all know by now that you
cannot comply your way out of tyranny
and the dutch are leading by incredible
example
okay so
i can't i can't really um comply your
way out of what t what tyranny are they
they're still protesting and bitching
about mandates have you i i have not ran
into any mandates
i live in trump country and they even
took down all the [ __ ] signs on the
stores that say
um wear a mask if you're not vaccinated
they took all those signs down like
they're not we're very forgetting about
that [ __ ] they there's no mandates
there's no
it's like the pandemic didn't even exist
since we got out of lockdown in 2020
here right what the [ __ ] are these
people yelling and screaming about well
it's the it's it is their des here you
know what it is
it's what i would consider a desire to
be oppressed right they want to be
oppressed so they can so they can take
that mantle is that the exactly because
if there's a good weapon if they're
because well here's here's the logic i
have in my head right now if you are not
oppressed you cannot be the victim and
if you're not the victim then you cannot
complain about those who are in power
those who are bigger than you have more
rights than you more responsibilities
than you
so
when you want to attack the government
she is right now saying we need a
revolution we need to stand up against
big government and big government is
trying to oppress us with these mandates
with all these rules with all these
things that are
rights and not rights and this and that
that is what she's trying to justify
here and so they want to be oppressed
just like the people who want to go into
bathrooms and look and see what people's
genders are or go into people's homes
and know are they [ __ ] or not it's
weird stuff it's their own desire their
own wants and that's what they want here
is they want to be the victim so they
can complain and [ __ ] and moan so when
they do something
like i don't know try to storm the
capital or try to run into an fbi office
with a [ __ ] nail gun
it's because they want to have
justification to say
we
are the little one here and we're trying
to stand up and fight against the big
one who's pushing us down when that's
well not at all the case well watch
watch how she what her call to action is
so why can't we do that here in america
why are we allowing these evil elites to
dictate our lives why can't we all man
the hell up and fight back
i don't know about you but i think it's
somewhat ignorant to rely solely on
elections to make these essential
changes that our country so desperately
needs when it's become abundantly clear
that our entire system is rigged and
corrupt why don't we the people get
organized and take the power back okay
so i want to point something out
that was that was a that was definitely
a kimberly guilfoyle moment there just
want to point that out right well here i
want to point something down here this
whole this whole [ __ ] that uh that
it's rigged against them it is rigged
against you it is rigged against you
democracy is rigged against your fascism
yeah it is rigged against you that is
why you are so [ __ ] pissed off you're
so pissed off because you don't realize
that democracy is rigged against your
[ __ ] core
world view which is i get to oppress
anyone i want to oppress democracy
demolishes that because we the people
can stand against you that's why they
hate elections that's why they they hate
elections they love insurrection and the
reason why is because insurrection is
not democracy it is not democracy and it
serves their interest to be violent not
speaking of violence you've seen this
[ __ ] i'm going to play this
video i'm not going to play all of it
but i want to point out that this little
this little [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] here
this little piece of [ __ ] is carrie
lake's mouth mouthpiece his her
messenger her head messenger on her
campaign
running around the state hunting lgbtq
people here in this video he wants to
put him in concentration camps as a
listen folks of the lgbt community are
raping and molesting their children
and their animals giving them monkey pox
you sick piece of [ __ ] you sick piece of
[ __ ] and that's that's his justification
here we go watch for support lgbt you
know we're gonna have to have them
uh shut down for uh public health
measures and um
step one step two is um all folks of the
lgbt community must self quarantine you
know if they affiliate with the
community
you know for their own safety and the
safety of others and for public safety
uh they're gonna have to self quarantine
and if they refuse we're gonna have to
hunt them down round them up and put
them into self-quarantined isolation
camps
and you might say you might say you know
it's too much to put gay people in
concentration camps
or solve quarantine camps you know
this is what they want folks this is the
rhetoric this is the [ __ ] and you
think oh this is just some guy on social
media this is who carrie lake is
supporting and he's supporting gary lake
this is who the person who wants to be
the governor in [ __ ] arizona
who who is getting her messaging from
the bonehead that they're getting their
messaging from so no it's not just some
some some little [ __ ] on social media
they are the republican party this is
who they are and as they dwindle down
their support to people like this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] there's gonna be
more and more that are gonna try to grab
power that think the way he thinks so
get it straight we got we have to be
vigilant we have to lean into democracy
and let's do that gabe let's do that by
by mocking these son of a [ __ ] but
first before we go to bone end of the
week i want to play this clip
of um it seems like i know is this a new
sitcom let's play this it seems like it
uh sorry interrupt but was it was there
a limited number of people who had
access to that storage room it seems
like a pretty important room right since
they've made such a big deal of it and
have the lock on it and so forth so were
there a limited number of people who
could go in and out
yes or have access to mar-a-lago it
certainly mar lava is secure in and of
itself you know just getting on to the
compound is hard and then it was a
locked door and getting you know back
down into the basement there's security
you can't just walk down there only
certain members of staff can get there
and then there's only one key so uh yes
it's a very limited number of people
that have access down there and
you know it was enough to where
president trump believed or our our team
believed that it was secure enough they
asked for one more lock at another lock
which we did
and then for whatever reason they
decided that they still needed to raid
the play
and if only one or two people had access
to that room to your knowledge
that's my understanding i mean i would
have to check with you know the the
maintenance of that area but my
understanding is very small number of
people that could get in there
so this seems like the actual
appropriate way to edit this video this
is the way it should have been
originally released i think
yeah yeah well shitty legal takes yeah
there's also another one there's more to
come huh there's no there's one okay
there's one more right now let's play
this one
yeah well there's three allegations
right concealment espionage and
basically destruction all of which don't
make sense to me knowing that he was
cooperating the entire time so if you
were concealing it you wouldn't have
allowed them in in june if you were
distracting it you wouldn't have added
the padlock that they asked you to laugh
all of these things as you've seen and
it's been reported have this caveat that
people get excited about which is that
he then cannot run for president what
they don't understand is presidents have
different privileges they have executive
privileges they have different things
that have been in place from bush george
w bush put in place obama used but no
one talks about that because if it's
trump they'd like to bring these
antiquated statutes and shove them down
his throat
so it appears whoever edited this yeah i
don't know
i don't know i don't know who put this
together but uh whoever whoever put this
together um is absolutely brilliant here
to put the laugh track
over top of where it actually should be
the laughable moments the lies i don't
know you know pat that
person on the back whoever did it i
don't know
well everyone what we'll do is we'll try
to put these together we'll put them on
social media so you have a chance to
spread them around and there's a third
one as well okay
uh we'll we'll post that one out yeah
we'll post that we'll get it on youtube
we'll post them separate and maybe we'll
make a playlist we'll put them on the uh
the parody and satire list yeah so don't
don't forget to follow the the um the
youtube channel here the tony michaels
podcast check out that parody and satire
list um for all these videos so so
hopefully we'll get those up this
afternoon and you guys can take a look
at those and we'll spread them around
the social media channels as well i mean
we don't want to deprive every one of
those
we are getting late into the second hour
so let's do this let's not deprive
everyone of the sh of the uh bone end of
the week that's what i meant to say so
let's let's do this let's go to a break
when we come back we will be back with
bonehead of the week
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100 made in the
usa don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just 99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome to the show
thanks for sticking around for a bone
end of the week we're getting laid into
the second hour but we're gonna do
bonehead it's gonna be a little bit of a
lightning round this time but we're
gonna get to it
let's not waste a lot of time
[Music]
gabe who do we have for bone end of the
week who do we have
we got some good ones we got some good
ones we've got some good ones good ones
i actually uh i messed up again and i
need you to put the uh whatever the
dishonorable mention is put it there in
the app why do you keep trying i don't
know i i i try to hit the right button
and i hit the i i go too fast what
button are you going to do damn fast see
look
remember who you download are like right
next to each other
right next to each other so what are you
deleting them from drive what do you do
yeah yeah so what happens folks is move
or what do you
know
move no and
drive when you go to download it and
drive you you can click remove or
download and like right next to you i
don't know why google does that
why
[Music]
i will say our art department does a
great job making sure all these are in
there at a reasonable time like not
waiting around for bonehead to start or
anything like that it's not like it's
not like the art department's working
and other things
right absolutely i mean we got we got a
lot of stuff going over here but bone
end of the week is the one of the most
important segments that we do so let's
start bone end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week where you vote you decide who
is the bone end of the week we break it
down gabe are you ready for this bone
end because we got a few of them let's
let's bring them up here we got senator
chuck grassley
ron desantis of florida that fascist and
who is this one on the end who is this
clown this is the joker without makeup
oh
she's the one who beat who beat darth
vader junior in in wyoming harriet
hegman she's hagman is that him
well
i would think it would be two g's now i
don't know names are pronounced so i
think you got it spelled wrong there i
mean no
no i think it well if that's the case no
i'm saying i'm saying just like
tony texted me a message last night of
him eating chips and and uh in salsa
salsa salsa salsa i'm from missouri san
diego even we even in the champ for the
missouri tigers it's m-i-z-z-o-u
and there's a z in missouri apparently
it's missouri
yeah yeah that doesn't translate
over to spanish
why i mean salsa that's how we say it
here you eat chips chips chips chips if
you're going to put the yes if you're
going to put the s on there you got to
put it you can put the z on the s you
got to put the z on the s for everything
on everything well
we could we could just run
xanders rhonda zambas and senator
senator jack
grassley
okay well who should we start with
should we start with this harriet hagman
yeah let's let's get her out of here we
go should we go with her is that who we
should go with first i mean what what i
mean other than she is
absolutely crazy
i mean and other other than other than
the doppelganger of carrie lake show a
video here of um
of harriet hegman um here she is on the
trafficking video i don't know here's
here she is on the parents to appears to
be sean hannity show let's listen that
congratulated you and wished you well
how did the call go
well there wasn't a phone call while i
does she look like she can blink it
looks like it's a struggle for her to
blink every i just want to say this
every time i see an interview with her
she's always like this
boom his eyes are wide open and i never
i never see her blink how much and she's
always like a person holy
alert she is alert folks
whoosh energy drinks coffee no this
person is probably going to be a member
of congress isn't that disheartening
that we're going to have we're going to
have lauren bobert marjorie taylor green
possibly this [ __ ] and the the queen of
morons sarah palin possibly in the
congress i'm going to meet a [ __ ]
caucus let's listen i was going in and
getting ready to do my acceptance speech
last night and had just arrived at the
watch party she called and left a very
brief two-second message on my on myself
why did she say what'd she say [ __ ] off
is that within like two seconds i mean
yeah but here's the thing off liz cheney
knew
she knew
that harriet hagman would do this
so then she released
the actual voicemail audio
to say
i know i know what you're going to do i
know what you're going to say
here's the actual voicemail yeah this is
the audio okay so here here's the audio
let's play this here
ap is calling it so we should go
all right here is liz chaney calling
it's about 8 13 on tuesday the 16th i'm
calling to concede the election uh and
to
to congratulate you on the win thanks
bye-bye
longer than two seconds longer than and
also also
the respect though i don't believe
harriet hagman deserves it
but the respect of following through and
saying i lost the election
i will call and concede and say
congratulations well and you know um
when an election is actually counted and
and it's valid and it's safe secure
it is uh it is appropriate for
regardless rather you're a politician
even more secure than the last election
because of all these accusations so
they're like well i guess we got to like
make sure that this [ __ ] isn't actually
broken i mean because this chain you can
say
stop the steal it's rigged it's rigged i
didn't i didn't i didn't lose i won
and be continuing this until now until
2030 to talk about how she won this
election even though there's three
elections in the meantime
okay well so it's pretty clear why she
ended up on bonehead of the week i mean
she also spreads a lot of lies around
biden she believes that biden she wanted
to you know did she say he's a human
trafficker or something yeah there was
uh let me see if i can find that video
this is coming from the person who
supports greg abbott who is who is
actually bussing human beings
trafficking them literally across the
united states because he doesn't like
the color of their skin
or the or the place they're from he's
trafficking them across the united
states jesus [ __ ] christ so i guess
that's why this bonehead ends up on bone
in the way why do we have chuck grassley
on here what's that what's the deal with
that guy
that what's that
is uh oh do you want to play the video
of her saying oh yeah real quick you got
it it's three seconds you're talking
about you're talking about hagman yeah
hagman okay let's let's play the video
in the back of hagman um
saying some really weird nonsense i mean
it isn't surprising as she's saying this
she's saying it on steve bannon's trader
tv i mean that's where this is right
yeah yeah this is it okay let's listen
joe biden is the largest or the most
destructive human trafficker in our
history i mean they absolutely project
here's more projection their party is
literally trafficking
people out of texas because they don't
like where they're from they don't like
the color their skin they don't like
their [ __ ] names and they're
trafficking human beings literally
busting them
through traffic on highways across the
country and there's dropping them off on
the side right but even more so it's
they're not telling them where they're
taking them right you know if you're
getting on a bus and you go into texas
let's say and then you're like oh greg
abbott he's deporting them he's taking
them back to you know well i guess i
don't know where they originated from it
could have mexico it could have been
guatemala could have been somewhere else
but the idea that they're like all right
we're just gonna
send him down to mexico we're gonna
deport them but that's not what they
tell them they either tell them a lie or
they don't tell them where they're
sending them at all which again if you
didn't want a certain group of people in
the country
which is like very unchristian of you in
terms of accepting those people and
sheltering them and caring for them and
giving them the support they need
instead of doing that you say
you don't belong here
and instead of then sending them outside
of the country because the whole problem
was them coming into the country they
then bust them to another part of the
country so they're not trying they're
not trying to solve a problem they're
trying to make this the problem bigger
for democrats but democrats are
accepting and saying great we will help
well but they're actually they're
actually helping
the economy by sending these people to
places where they need people to do jobs
to labor i mean we need labor in some of
these places the reason why you're so
frustrated when you go to places
sometimes and and they they either don't
have enough help or they don't have
enough people to to do the service that
you want as quickly as you want it's
because they don't have the labor so
it's sending these these buses of people
who absolutely are willing to work and
want to be part of america want to be
part of our economy and sending them to
places where we need this labor like
that's the actually one of the reasons
why our economy is it has is having such
trouble is because for [ __ ] five
years
five years they struggled to get the
labor in this country
they absolutely did not want anyone who
wanted to come here to be a part of the
american economy who wanted to give
labor because of the color their skin or
where they're from or their name and the
fact that they're like oh well you know
us as republicans we want to keep this
country white because that's what they
want to do they want it white because
white is right according to republicans
but here's the problem with their logic
by allowing more people who aren't white
into this country
they're creating a more diverse
and eclectic country the real goal of
what america was right this american
dream this melting pot of cultures and
people and languages and in skin colors
that's what america should be and that's
what america strives to be but
republicans say no it's got to be white
because that's right and then they're
[ __ ] over their own plan by allowing
more people who aren't white into the
country so
they they [ __ ] up every time right well
they're always there they're always
over playing their hands speaking of
crusty white dudes that overplay their
hand here's chuck grassley and
apparently the reason why he's on bone
of the week is he overplayed his hand
here he is in a
town hall a town hall style meeting um
if you notice there's a common
denominator here in this meeting but
let's listen to what chuck grassley
tells these folks in this meeting
probably hundreds of thousands of iowans
we're struggling to pay their insulin
why can't we do something about that so
this uh this voter here in iowa is
asking uh uh uh
general krusty here i i think he's
probably he's probably the last living
remnant of the civil war is it wasn't
truck isn't chuck grassley old enough to
actually chuck grassley his his uh his
social security number is one oh okay
he's gay it was the very first one what
that means he's the first one
he came out they came out and he was
like we should probably figure out some
sort of numbering people well let's
let's let's see what chuck grassley's
response here to his constituent who is
worried about affording insulin let's
see what he says because i think this
might be important there might be an
important vote coming up uh after this
clip was taken let's listen i'm for the
35
and
senator shaheen
from new hampshire
senator collins
from
maine are working on bipartisan jail to
do that
oh well it would be nice if we could get
senators like chuck grass he voted
against it right so for people who i
know i know the audio was low because a
couple people asked the question the
audit was low but basically the guy was
asking about um the cash on insulin
right right and he's 35 dollars will i
support capping not only that not only
that he brings up a a piece of
legislation that his republican
colleagues are working on to try to make
this accomplished exactly and he tells
his constituents
he says
well he said he would do it and he
didn't do it he didn't do it he voted
against it
right so anyone in iowa anyone in iowa
who has family members who are are not
even on insulin who want to make sure
that you you again engage in your ballot
and engage in your democracy tell all
your family and friends especially your
[ __ ] republican uncle earl yeah that
chuck grassy is a [ __ ] liar he's a
[ __ ] liar and he will continue to lie
to you and he's not just lying to you
about the thirty five dollars right yeah
like that's the little lie he's okay
with that little lie there's a lot of
big lies that he's telling you to do so
[ __ ] chuck grassley um i'm i'm i'm not
surprised that he ended up on this list
now we have um an alpha cuck and a
dishonorable mention what should i do
first you want to do the alpha cup first
you want to yeah let's do the alpha cook
okay here's the alpha cuck for the week
allen why sober wait i this name sounds
familiar ellen eiselberg is this the
same allen weissenberger is completely
[ __ ] in new york
yeah you know just to clear it up yes he
may look like grumpy cat okay let's go
back but
he he does he's totally ashamed he looks
like you know the the you didn't edit
this in any way to make it i didn't look
like i didn't do anything i just took a
photo or rather i took a photo that was
on the internet and i just cropped out
his face that's all i did it looks like
he's trying to it looks like he's trying
to smell his lip or something well keep
in mind this is a photo now the original
photo is him in focus and trump in
in the front he's behind him oh this is
the famous this is the famous where he's
standing behind trump because he was he
was basically second in charge yeah at
the trump org and that's the real story
here and i've been saying this for
months and months and months ever since
he was indicted that yeah it's not just
him indicted it's it's the trump crime
organization right the trump crime
organization is also indicted on
criminal charges now the most
significant part of this because a lot
of people don't feel like he got enough
time but i don't know if anyone knows
about rikers or not yeah but two days in
rikers probably seems like a hundred
years but he's supposed to go to rikers
for five months that's what the judge
has sentenced but we'll probably only do
three right correct because he'll get
because it's a state charge he'll get
parole uh he'll have a parole officer
yeah that's assuming that's assuming
that rikers and the stress of rikers
doesn't actually get right because
they're kind of overloaded right right
right yeah so that well i mean i was
going to say like just the stress of
going to rikers like the health
of himself because he is an old dude
yeah he's really grumpy he's really
grumpy yeah yeah he's grumpy cat like
that doesn't do anything
here's the picture yeah look at that
yeah the grumpy cat right there i'm
telling you
but going to rikers one it's you know
one of the most infamous prisons there
are in the united states it's [ __ ]
gross it is definitely a place no human
being wants to be right sure not even
the people who work there want to be
there yeah so the fact that he'll be
there potentially from three to five
months before he has his next appearance
right well and the other thing that the
judge made sure to tell alan weisselberg
is that he basically told him you better
tell the truth all right um
i'm giving you the max which i think is
17 years right right so so alan
weisselberg even though he seems like
he's out of the woods with his
five-month sentence of writers he is not
out of the woods here because he has to
actually he actually has to help the
state in the charges against the trump
crime organization which
i would imagine could turn into federal
charges pretty damn quickly um when the
evidence starts to be uncovered from the
chief financial officer the number two
in charge of the tax fraud organization
the the russian money laundering machine
that is the trump crime organization so
i think i think i think he
he is a great alpha cuck this week
because he's definitely going to cuck
in rikers yeah yeah well also i mean the
main reason i put him on the list here
for was because of the fact like
he was willing to testify against i mean
because he was forced to willing to
testify against the trump org right cut
a deal
but was still unwilling to do that for
trump
so he was unwilling to actually comment
and put any sort of disparaging or
uh you know crucial information to make
a case against trump now i'm sure they
obviously already have a case against
him and they're building stuff
um but
well this tax fraud this tax fraud this
tax scheme that they had didn't just
because there's a civil case against the
trump organization the trump crime
family um for the state of new york as
well not just this criminal case there's
a civil case where they're going to try
to cut this the trump organization down
like a fresh-cut tree and i would
imagine tish james right now is
sharpening her acts like abraham lincoln
yeah you know
and and i i would imagine i would
imagine that tis james is going to aim
and cut it down
uh very appropriately now the question
is rather the feds probably get a hold
of what these crimes that allen
weisselberg are going to expose um and
rather there's cooperation between the
manhattan da's office and the southern
district of new york
in these in this
tax fraud scheme that probably wasn't
just for the state of new york but was
also for our government and that's why
he never wanted us to see his tax
returns because there was crime in them
and i'm sure that's exactly what the
manhattan d.a is going to have evidence
of to charge the trump organization with
crime which means the feds can probably
step in at some point we'll see we'll
see if there's a federal case to be made
in new york we definitely know there's
one uh in florida now and there's one in
dc possibly one in georgia as well so
he's he's facing four federal districts
that possibly will bring cases speaking
of georgia
speaking of georgia we have a
dishonorable mention yeah this person
hails
from georgia yep and i i don't know
maybe maybe she um maybe she lost her
extra toe that people are supposed to
have in georgia marjory hoof foot green
is our dishonorable mention why is she
our dishonorable mention today game what
what what is that
she introduced a bill to make gender
affirming care for transgender
she tweeted out the photo of her at
bedminster with trump and tucker carlson
she's like i got a big announcement to
make on tucker carlson tonight and
everyone's like oh is she gonna say that
she's gonna be his running mate in 2024
is she gonna uh talk about another
affair she had with someone that wasn't
a tantric sex guru or wasn't the uh
crossfit manager or is she going to you
know maybe she reveals hey i've got an
extra toe surgery that's coming up to
replace the missing one that i have i
don't know but basically the measure
would make it that it's a class c felony
which is punishable up to 25 years in
prison for doctors or anyone else who
provides gender affirming health care to
a minor
that she even wants to include adults
doesn't she yeah this is this is the
bone-headed tweet here um
she acts like she's not on twitter but
she's definitely on twitter she's like
oh they banned me i'm censored no you're
not a [ __ ] account that you tweet
from all the time she tweeted here
tonight
i'll be joining tucker carlson for a big
announcement
tune in to fox news at 8 pm here's the
picture that she posted
um of her like i love when he puts that
stubby finger in my face that little
stubby finger that's so gross look at
this little hands
look at look at look at oh god
look at this he does have tiny hands
doesn't he
have i mean even tucker carlson marjorie
taylor green has bigger hands than he
does yeah yeah no it's uh maybe we
should get some kind of measurement on
this picture or something to to to uh to
convince this was the last time people
saw tucker crosston
is it really
well i mean you got to imagine like what
happened after this right you he oh yeah
yeah yeah he had this golf tournament
and then the search warrant happens and
then tucker carlson was not going for
like a week
it was gone people started subbing in
for him and want to be tucker
to be on tv gabbard coming in and with
the other guy that
tried to be tucker like these are all
people that
uh had to had to replace him because he
was gone on vacation i don't know you
know
it's really it's really [ __ ] gross
here is the um
here's the clip i think of her announced
giving her a big announcement that um
she's gonna sleep with donald trump i
mean um
try to be a bigot uh right out in the
open like she is let's listen let me
tell you something yeah this is a
referendum on the republican party
when we take back the majority if the
american people elect us we need we have
a lot of work to do not only do we need
to impeach merit garland we need to
clean out the corrupt fbi we need to
hold the democrats accountable and
defund all of their climate garbage 87
claimant garbage
forget the climate [ __ ] the climate the
climate can go to hell
i mean maybe we could shoot it down with
lasers and just like i guess
i mean you know their bigotry is working
for him i guess maybe maybe not worrying
about the climate actually being
anti-climate will help let's listen 1000
irs army but there's one thing that we
have got to do and we're not even a
party worth deserving of the american
people's votes if we cannot protect
children from this horrific child abuse
and create this to be a felony because
this practice has to end it's the case
it's the kind of things nightmares are
made of and these are monsters under
kids beds that are doing these horrific
things to them
literally literally her party in
tennessee is the one that want to marry
children yeah this is the she she said
one truth in there she said we do not
deserve the vote of the american people
right
that part i would say is absolutely 100
true because people like marjory taylor
greene people like tucker carlson people
like ted cruz
all of these people
will stab constituents in the back but
not only that
they want to be the people that go into
your home
pull up pull down your pants pull up
your skirt whatever right well yeah they
definitely are obsessed with your
genitalia they love
they love to look at those things they
love to make sure is that really what
you are
those are the things that will
catastrophically
traumatize someone
and make them know or make them think
about
the boogeyman or the monster under the
bed like she says they're the party that
will make anyone and everyone afraid
of what will happen if they take control
which is we want to make sure that you
are who you say you are right what
gender are you
well
speaking speaking of speaking of bigots
i want to move to because we're we're
getting low on time here and i want to
make sure we give the winner plenty of
time uh we know the winner is governor
ron desantis that [ __ ] that nazi that
let's go brandon nazi down in florida
he's really working on a fascist state
but gabe there's some breaking news here
just in the last few hours a judge has
declared ron desantis back florida law
that restricts race-based conversation
and analysis in business and
education unconstitutional
uh the tallahassee us district mark
walker said the stop woke act violates
the first amendment and is in its
it's [ __ ] it's absolute [ __ ] and garbage
here's the thing
the the stop woke act
is stopping from people from expressing
and practicing their first amendment
right
well again the chelsea handler clip that
i played from earlier
the bone ends don't even they skip right
over this first amendment yeah the only
thing they get from first amendment is i
get to say whatever i want without
consequences which is not what it says
and then the second one the likes to
second amendment lets me have guns and
kill whoever i want to kill especially
my enemies who who want to give me
consequences for my speech on the first
one and again they don't understand
these amendments they don't and they
just don't get that you can say whatever
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] you want to say but
it's just the reason why is this the
reason why he was on bone of the week or
did we have not just one the original
reason was because of his attack towards
teachers right he was attacking teachers
this week to say like uh you know most
people
you know well one he was he was going
after um
well he went
then he went after um teachers and
uh
um
uh and tenure which is a debatable topic
but he went after that and then he also
was like look if you're a veteran who
has 60 credits or more of from from a
college
oh yes
and teach our classes right but then he
also was like oh you know these people
you know get their education and i don't
really like the argument that he made
was basically
people who go to school to learn
teaching type stuff i forget how we
phrased it but it was something dumb
like that like he said um
who who go to study like teaching or the
practice of teaching or whatever the
[ __ ] it was
he
says oh you know because i don't really
believe in that stuff right like you can
go to that and you can practice it but i
don't really think it works right that's
what his argument was saying right
people go to school to become an
educator
to learn practices and protocols and how
you know you know how they should go
about teaching a class of anywhere from
uh young children to adults right and he
basically saying like ah yeah
you could you don't have to go to
college for that you have to get a
master's in that you don't have to get a
phd whatever it is depending on the the
level that you want to teach at
that is what he was arguing and that was
my biggest complaint this week was the
fact that he was attacking teachers and
saying you actually don't need to go to
any sort of training as long as you took
some college credits
that's good enough for me well the other
thing is keep everyone [ __ ] done the
other reason i believe is because he
announced that he was going to arrest
some people who voted illegally
and you know he's he's throwing out all
these things that there's big election
fraud and i think there's like three
people that they're gonna arrest for
election run but he failed he failed to
do the same thing when those boneheads
at the villages he failed to have the
big huge press
when the trump supporters voted three
and four times at the villages the the
highest concentration of voter fraud in
the entire country in florida at the
villages for in the name of donald trump
so he failed to recognize that so ron
desantis of course appropriately is the
winner here you decided that ron
desantis was the winner i almost believe
that i think ron desantis would possibly
win even if donald trump was on this
thing what do you think it's possible i
mean like look if he's such a [ __ ]
bonehead
yeah you know we could see we could see
we could take it as a as a a more of a
metric to see like who would perform
well in a 2024 presidential poll hey we
should do a poll we should do a 2024
bonus as soon as this election's over
yeah i don't want to get ahead of
ourselves this is the most important
election so as soon as this election's
over i tell you that the most important
election is going to be the next one as
soon as this one's over so let's
consider that around those holidays to
really put out a poll to see who is
going to be the bone end of 2024 i like
that idea but let's let's do this
let's not waste much time let's give ron
desantis the fascist let's go brandon
nazi down in florida
dude dumming america down dumbing them
down banning math banning book fairs
bone end of the week ron desantis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ron desantis bone end of the week well
deserved i don't know this is probably
the third or fourth time he's been the
bone of the week this guy could
be on the list again we could have like
15 people on the list consistently
yeah and they would i mean if i really
wanted to i could go back every week to
see who actually yeah well yeah and i
could have and then i could you have
like record setters and stuff you know
do you do some uh
yeah
here's here's the thing about um this
bonehead because i i forgot to show a
clip earlier in the show of someone
running for governor who actually uh
could be a governor who could be a real
governor for the people and not only is
he showing a way
to be a governor and to get out there
and talk to his community you know we've
been talking a lot about community gabe
here on the tony michael's podcast but
um i want to show you there was a bunch
of boneheads speaking of bonehead of the
week that showed up in support of greg
abbott at a better aurora community
meeting where he was talking to real
people real community members no telling
where these people came these bone heads
came from
watch
watch how better aurora
deals with greg abbott boneheads this is
[ __ ] fantastic
hey listen um lest we be
annoyed or judge these avid people
let's have a little bit of sympathy
their candidate never shows up to talk
to them
damn
oh
i love this guy i [ __ ] love this guy
if you guys missed it what better orc
what's happening here is uh inside the
community hall here where he's talking
to his constituents who are going to
vote for him to be an actual governor of
the state of texas um and he's trying to
work through their issues and tell them
about their issues and hear what they're
saying listening to them having
conversations with them even even
turning trump supporters to be better
voters signing hats signing hats
trump hats maga hats it's it's
incredible to watch it's incredible to
see this happening in front of our eyes
but the abbott supporters are standing
outside chanting and yelling right yeah
so they're trying they're trying to stop
him from talking
so they're yelling and screaming and
then what he points out very uh
he just dunks on him just i mean you
remember the game nba jam oh yeah he's
the sega game
he's on fire
just [ __ ] dunks on him he says from
downtown
he says you got to feel sorry for these
folks outside yelling and screaming
their actual candidate won't come and
actually talk to them yeah um which is
what's even worse is their candidate
won't even show up to the funeral right
for the victims from the uvalde school
shooting pretty good that's how much of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] bag
greg abbott is he won't even show up he
has no empathy no
sense of remorse or sadness or any
ability to relate to his constituents
that he will show up to one of the worst
massacres that they've had in in in
recent history
right i mean there's el paso as well
but the guy doesn't show up the only
time he ever has a conference is when
the nra's involved or other people who
are trying to gaslight victims well when
he's trying to women's well when he's
trying to take women's rights away when
he's trying to make sure that teenagers
are forced to have
babies all kinds of great stuff that
greg abbott's doing or not doing for his
constituents and beto so strategically
with a knife in front of his crowd and
you notice how the crowd responds
because they know exactly what beto was
talking about the people in this room
have felt abandoned abandoned by their
fascist governor greg abbott and beto
is not abandoning them he's there with
them he's talking to him he's listening
to them and that's the most important
thing about community and the most
important thing about our democracy
so make sure you do the thing in
democracy engage in your ballot but the
other place you can vote is on twitter
at tony michael's pod for bonehead of
the week every single week gabe we do it
every week
the second hour of the show bone end of
the week every friday
the other thing we do gabe is we
actually put it up on all the podcast
directors so you can download apple
spotify google on sunday
subscribe to the youtube channel so you
don't miss bonehead of the week a replay
on sunday
sunday sunday sunday so subscribe to the
youtube channel right here
at the tony michaels podcast do not mess
a single s episode of the tony michaels
podcast or bonehead of the week
congratulations to ron desantis for
winning again bone end of the week this
week uh stick around stick around
bonehead might be over but we have a few
announcements right after this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love that that's my favorite segment i
love that segment i mean i love it i
like how we like roll through the thing
you know oh here's the dm and here's the
elbow i like that kind of that rhythm
that we have you know it's a little
different than the shitless round though
because the shitless around it would
just kind of serve and well the [ __ ]
list is just whatever it is right right
there's at least some format to make
bonehead you know the structure format
there's a structure you know what to
expect the great music yeah the great
intro
the graphics are there these things are
all
setting the pace here at the tony
michaels podcast and for pro-democracy
speech everywhere
we are setting the bar folks with
bonehead of the week so don't forget to
support pro-democracy speech to support
our show the link is down below
support.tonymichaelspod.com
there's a qr code if you can figure out
how that works i'm a boomerang i don't
know i think you are yeah
but if you know just go down in the go
down in the chat you can ask mj one of
our moderators i think she knows how it
works maybe she's figured out robin and
midas margie our moderators are three
moderators give some love this week to
the moderators they've done such a great
job this week we now have three
moderators we're so happy to have them
show them love in the chat as much as
you possibly can we appreciate having
them here they are the best moderators
the moderators of the moderators of the
moderators baby
we love them thank you very much for for
helping us in the chat there and keeping
it going folks don't forget to subscribe
to the tony michaels podcast you're not
going to want to miss the chat with our
moderators so subscribe hit the bell
notification we're here every single
weekday
two hours monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and simulcasting
from the facebook page and i would be
derelict in my duty gabe if i did not
mention the chat over on the facebook
page of midas touch they are they are
chatting away over there as well so you
can very active very very active on you
can also chat from twitch don't forget
the twitch the twitter's the twitter's
over there people on twitch over there
you can't chat from the uh the twitter
you can put it in but we don't yeah but
we don't see it yeah so so if you want
come over and you can actually um
participate in the chat here on youtube
so subscribe to the youtube channel
don't forget that but also also download
every single episode every single
weekday two full hours and if you don't
want to re-listen to the full hours
that's okay we have a best of on
saturday gabe that we do that we
download to apple spotify google your
favorite what the hell your favorite
director
you know
it's friday and he's doing all kinds of
crazy yeah you know it's friday have a
little fun tony thank you
podcast it's not all about being serious
you know what fellaini friday is what it
is felony friday that's what they're
calling it i think so maybe we'll have
some more people pleading guilty to
felonies today
so download every single episode seven
days a week because you can download
every two hour episode monday through
friday but saturday's the best of sunday
is bone end of the week so don't forget
to download those episodes
i enjoy having all the new audience here
we have so many new people in the
audience gabe there's the downloads are
up the views are up the audience
watching live is up you guys are for
democracy you are here to lean in to
your ballot and i am so happy to have
you here until monday same time same
place live on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page noon eastern we'll see you
then until then have a great weekend
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born had asked me